so in a normal country in a normal time
this would be a huge story this would be
front page of every paper in the country
the city of oakland california across
the bay from san francisco
has just announced a plan to give 500 a
month to families who make under 59
grand a year
okay there's only one criterion they
have to have the correct
skin color certain people are ineligible
because of how they were born
that's obviously racist craziness
but the mayor of oakland libby schaff
says it's very important because it will
quote
close the racial wealth gap
today oakland california launches one of
the largest
guaranteed income demonstrations to date
in the nation
600 oakland families will receive 500
a month for 18 months our vision
is in oakland that has closed the racial
wealth gap
and where all families thrive
so funny what like a terrifying ego trip
a lot of these small town politicians
are on if you go to an airport anywhere
all of a sudden the mayor announces over
the loudspeaker i'm the mayor
there's libby schaff doing her star turn
for her weird racist program that no
one's talking about but people should be
because it's important
jason rantz is a seattle radio host
and a frequent guest on the show we're
glad to have him jason thanks so much
for coming on this would seem to violate
not just federal law but the basic
precept of america which is the
government treats us all equally
regardless of how we were born
why is no one mentioning this well maybe
recently no one's mentioning
it because they scrubbed this part of
the program from their website
last week at least as of thursday was
mentioning that so-called bipac
communities would be getting
access exclusively to this and then i
guess white people
are not worthy of any kind of financial
assistance
if they're poor but now if you go to
their website it's not there
but yes you're correct this seems
inherently illegal it is of course
incredibly racist you and i would be
having the same conversation
if they came up with a program that was
giving money exclusively to white people
everyone would be talking about that and
we would be right to talk about that
but under this guise of social justice
and equity
they're basically claiming uh mayor
schaff claims that
the reason why there's poverty in
communities of color is because the
systems are failing folks that this is
not any kind of personal failure that
it's essentially
because of institutionalized racism
which is what they do
to to basically justify not helping
white people as if
the poor white folks are choosing not to
engage in their
white privilege not cashing that check
to somehow get out of poverty it's
absolutely ludicrous and by the way it's
counterproductive
because i don't think the data backs up
this program
well that's exactly right look at the
labor department's stats
nigerian immigrants make more on average
and are better educated than native born
whites so like what is this it's just so
stupid and crazy jason rants i
appreciate you're coming on tonight
thank you
thank you tucker